Conclusion, qui sait?
♪ ♪ ♪
rois fois rois fois rois fois rs
que la circonscription
de Bourassa-Sauvé.
- On va te faire un beau tour
d'oreille, comme dans les années
1950.de nombreux hommes et femms
politiques depuis 60 ans.
DELLE DONNE, barbier
- Quand quelqu'un veut une belle
coiffure pour faire des posters,
pour fainent voir Giacomo.
(rire)
- Et la légende raconte
qu'un passage dansonymeonymeonye
de victoire à l'élection.
D'ailleu chefs est
déjà venu cette année. Il nous
dira qui, un peu plus tard.-Saue
le territoire de Montréal-Nord,
un secteun secteun secteun secùs
ne se font pas prier pour
- On a le coût de la vie.
- La santé et la sécurité.un arr
mal famé. Mais ça a commencéà d.
- Si certains voient une
embellie, cette question de
cesse aux oreilles des candidats
en campagne.
compter sur votre appui,
vous pensez. Vous continuez
r à ça?
- Oui, pourquoi pas.
- Merci!- Merci beaucoup!
- Oui.- La mission de Madwa-Nika
Cadet : perpétuer la longue
tradition de victoire
- Moi, je crois pas à ça,
les châteaux forti,
je pense que chaque campagne,
ça se gagne sur le terrain.
- En répmatière
de sécurité :
MADWA-NI
candidate, PLQ, Bourassa-Sauvé
- Nous, au Parti libéral
vestir 90 millions de
dollars en prévention pour
er auprès des organismes
communautaires, pour travailler
auprès des organismes qui ont-Çe
aux oreilles de la directricede,
mais des années d'inaction
politique ou d'actions
HODA ESSASSI, DG, Table
de quartier de Montréal-Nord
- Montréal-Nord c'est
un quartier où o
Donc, il y a eu la crise après
les émeutes à la écès
de Freddy Villanueva, il y a eu
aussi une crise des demandeurs
d'asile en 2016-2017, ensuite
il y a e de la COVID,
et puis tout ça a été ponctué
par des crises de violence
urbaine. Et on travailletoujour.
Et ça, pendant 20 ans, ça n'a
pas transformé le quartier.
- Avec de très no
partenaires, elle vient
d'élaborer le premier plan de
développement soci
celles et ceux qui aspirent
à les représenteron connaon con.
Mais si, après ça, on passe pass
citoyens sont... sceptiques.us s
que compte la candidate
le secteur.
CARMEL-ANTOINE BESSARD,
candidate, PCQ, Bourassa-Sauvérs
chez eux, ils vont aller voter.
Et moi, e population-
là que je dois aussi aller
chercher, ceux qui ne votent
- Et il y a un terreau fertile
- Oui, bien décidé pour
teur. Oui, pour
reprendre la liberté du Québec.
Oui, absolument.r, qui avait une
sensibilité plus libérale avantr
la balance avec le parti
qui soutient les entrepreneu
de Montréal-Nord, justement.
Et c'est le cas du Parti
conservateur.
- ...Qui a fait imprimer che
lui son matériel de campagne.
D'autres électeurs songent
à quitter le navire libéral
- Moi, je vote les libéraux,
généralement. Donc, je suis
vus par les libéraux. Mais je
trouve que le premier ministre,
Il se pourrait que je change
mon fusil d'épaule
la prochaine fois.didate de la t
qu'elle peut capitaliser
sur les déçus. Elle compte leou.
ABSA DIALLO,candidatcandidatcané
- Moi, ce qui me tient à coeur,
je veux dire, je suis médecinles
Bourassa-Sauvé, c'est là que
l'on retrouve le plus de gens
famille.
- Réplique de la candidate
libérale :
l'accès à un médecin de famille
a doublé dans les
dernières années.
- Dans cette circonscription où,
après les Haïdududududududududuu
Maghreb, Québec solidaire espère
faire de
des critiques de la loi 21
ôté, le Parti Québécois
nourrit des espoirs mesurés, lui
qui figure en cinquième position
À propos de l'issue du vote,
Giacomo sera-t-il
de cette élection?
Celui qui est venu s'asseoir
sur son
- Éric Duhaime. Il voulait
e cheveux.
- Mais cette fois, le barbier
s'est bien gardé de prophétiser
sa victo
Ici Mathieu Prost